monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les ministres mes chers
collègues ma question s'adresse à
monsieur le ministre de l'économie des
finances et de la relance la fermeture
partielle ou totale des cafés débits de
boissons des restaurants ou encore des
hôtels par manque de clients est une
mesure qui concerne de plus en plus de
territoire aujourd'hui l'explosion du
nombre de contaminations de ces derniers
jours nous permet de douter de
l'efficacité de ces mesures
et en dépit des protocoles sanitaires la
question dure confinement refait surface
lors de la première vague le
gouvernement s'est montré assez réactif
sur la prise des mesures compensatoires
à l'arrêt d'activité des établissements
recevant du public tels que nos hôtels
ou encore les bars et restaurants
néanmoins le 2 le défi aujourd'hui est
tout autre alors que nous entrons dans
une seconde vague sans doute plus
violente et plus longue
les professionnels du tourisme peuvent
se satisfaire de 2002 mesures
compensatoires et doivent se voir
proposer un vrai horizons le
gouvernement a présenté un plan france
relance qui prétend faire la france de
demain faire la france de demain c'est
s'appuyer sur ses forces et notamment
sur ces territoires
le tourisme en fait partie les
professionnels de ce secteur offrent des
emplois durables non délocalisables ce
sont également des savoir-faire que le
monde entier nous envie
il faut penser à demain un jour nous
vaincrons le virus et en attendant nous
devons préserver la filière du tourisme
et de l'hôtellerie restauration aussi et
avant les nouvelles annonces de ce soir
pourriez vous nous préciser ce que le
gouvernement prévoit pour permettre à
ces métiers qui met en valeur nos
territoires de s'adapter concrètement
aux mesures imposées par la situation
sin finances sanitaire pardon également
comme vous le savez déjà et avant la
crise sanitaire
la filière hôtellerie-restauration
peinait à recruter pour que notre
pourquoi ne pas faire de cette période
troublée une opportunité pour favoriser
la formation de nos jeunes à ces
nombreux métiers par des dispositifs
innovants de formation à distance ou en
présentiel dans les établissements
hôteliers et de restauration désormais
fermée au public
nous nous devons monsieur le ministre
d'anticiper l'avenir pour préserver
cette filière particulièrement touchée
au complot la parole est au secrétaire
d'état chargé de la transition numérique
et des communications électroniques
monsieur cédric haut pour vous répondre
le président madame la sénatrice du
musée l'absence qui est retenue par les
dernières consultations préalables aux
annonces de 7 ce soir du président de la
république
précisément avec les secteurs je crois
que vous évoquez ou non le maire à ce
titre a eu l'occasion de le rappeler
lundi dernier à l'assemblée nationale ce
que nous cherchons à faire notre
objectif c'est bien de conjuguer la
lutte contre l'épidémie
avec le maintien de l'activité et la
protection économique
dans une situation sanitaire olivier
ferrand et le premier ministre ont
rappelé tout à l'heure qui est
extrêmement inquiétante et notre
première responsabilité est de freiner
le plus efficacement possible la
propagation du virus tout en permettant
à notre autonomie de près de produire
c'est pourquoi l'ensemble du ministère
de l'économie des finances et de la
relance est mobilisée pour soutenir les
secteurs les plus fragilisées à savoir
notamment ce secteur des cafés hôtels
restaurants et ceux qui en dépendent
rappelez peut-être ce qui a été fait
jusqu'ici
d'abord que le fonds de solidarité a été
simplifié renforcée et élargie pour
toutes les entreprises sans exception
toutes les entreprises de moins de 50
salariés installés dans les zones de
couvre-feu et subissant une perte de 50
% de leur chiffre d'affaires peuvent
avoir accès à une aide mensuelle allant
jusqu'à 1500 euros
j'ajoute par ailleurs que les
entreprises d'au moins 50 salariés de ce
secteur des chr peuvent désormais
bénéficier de l'aide de 10000 euros si
elles ont perdu 50% sans condition de
plafonnement de chiffre d'affaires je
rappelle que les exonérations de charges
ont été massivement renforcé et que le
chômage partiel indemnisé à 100% pour
ces secteurs a été prolongé jusqu'à la
fin de l'année je vais vous assurez
madame la sénatrice mais plus largement
la chambre haute que les mesures
d'urgence seront adaptés aux dispositifs
annoncés ce soir par le président de la
république à cet effet monsieur le
premier ministre détaillera devant la
chambre haute demain à 14h30 les mesures
prises pour lutter contre la propagation
la colle de la copie de 19 je crois que
dans cette période nous devons
collectivement prendre nos
responsabilités nous devons protéger
sanitairement et économiquement et je
veux à ce titre vous réitérer notre
engagement nous ne laisserons aucune
entreprise sur le bord de la route vers
la reprise
je vous remercie